the great american foodie fest who is
sponsoring this next segment returns to
henderson for its 10th year wow julian
joins us live with the preview hey
jillian
hey rocky and jc yes we are celebrating
10 years of good food and good fun out
here at the great american foodie fest i
am joined by oliver we are in front of
one of my favorite food trucks strip
cheese but it's just one of the many you
can check out here so oliver let's talk
about it this is family friendly when
people come in what can they experience
oh they can experience live
entertainment we have a huge carnival
gourmet food trucks and specialty food
vendors that you don't find here locally
get a little bit of everything out here
and as we're looking around here there's
a lot of rides i think you should
probably go on the rides before you eat
at the food trucks would that be your
advice to people oh i agree i agree 100
well let's walk around and explore a
little bit i see funnel cakes we see
corn dogs ice cream it's a lot of fun
out here why do you think this has been
so successful for the last 10 years
we just tried to provide something
special for the community to come to
just come and enjoy themselves and and
everyone loves food so
hey you can't go wrong and we're
actually passing by something really
cool you also have a vip area over here
right we do because we wanted to bring
something back that we've had in the
past and since this is our 10-year
anniversary we wanted to add that that
feature back in
all right well we're walking around
everything starts at 5 pm tonight can
you give us the hours really quickly
we're here in the parking lot at the
galleria mall correct so friday is 5 to
11. saturday is 12 to 11 and sunday is
12 to 10. so plenty of time to enjoy the
food oliver i'm going to give you one
job all you have to do is hold the
microphone for me okay um we are
stopping over here at vito's tacos and i
hear that they prepared a little
something so look at the oh my gosh this
looks amazing can you tell us what it is
so that's gonna be our slow cooked beef
uh beef beer yeah uh it's gonna be our
mozzarella cheese um our secret oil that
we dip it in uh takes about seven hours
to cook our beef wow
uh seventeen different spices
our fresh green salsa right there has a
little bit of avocado also our red salsa
is really spicy has about three
different chilies on your cilantro and
there's a lime on the side right there
oh my gosh this sounds like a lot of
flavors okay i'm kind of a wimp with
spice but i think i'm just gonna take a
bite go with the green what a flavor
okay i'm gonna take a bite you know i
couldn't hang out here without having a
bite of food right so as i'm eating this
i'll send it back to you guys and then
i'm going to go check out some of the
games and you know put my skills to the
test maybe i'll win you guys something
and bring it back for now i'll send it
back to you guys in the studio